guy who did nothing gets the first
credit Sony must have said we'll give
you this money only if the logo takes up
three-fifths of the screen and also
greatness awaits documentary what kind
of drill in 1982 no less makes a perfect
Reese's Cup shake these books are
completely rearranged in various
interview shots with this sociology
professor now I realize they probably
interviewed her multiple times for their
documentary and her clothes are even
different but why would a prominent
sociology professor take the time to
completely rearrange her bookshelf like
this then the documentary director
notice and care about continuity sine
gets you all excited about free
abortions but buries the lead about
penis enlargement the not on this guy's
tie is listen very closely to this
briefing for all subsequent briefings
you may go back to not paying attention
Lea's on the teachers become incredibly
obsessed with cat-food something about
that was like catnip for cats only a lot
more intense you obviously have never
seen cats with actual catnip because it
really can't get more intense there we
go look whatever your personal political
opinion is on alien abortions can't we
all agree that maybe it's a bad idea to
be this gleeful about it twenty year
project to save fuel that turns humans
and aliens conveniently completed
moments before the mnu raid but it's
actually Foxtrot Yankee five-30 honestly
with over a million prawns you can't
seriously expect to pull off this
massive vixen when you can't even get
the shack numbers right anytime a movie
forces you to watch someone's fingernail
fall off that's a sin how does this
alien ship hover over the city
indefinitely you can't do the job I'll
find someone who get then what was with
all this promotion that wives that start
banging on the bathroom door after their
husbands have only been in there for 30
seconds or a sin he wasn't going to get
that as a few
each and every one of you is a hard
target search every gas station
residents good we come to the ironic
overly happy couple answering machine
message cliche visionary science fiction
director rips off the inanimate object
perspective camera work from Breaking
Bad and then you decides not to take a
wanted criminal off of their security
database nick has sprayed some of this
goo in his face then how can there be
enough left to power the spaceship
thinking wasn't he saving fluid for 20
years to get the right amount selfish
hero chooses selfishly only to then
change his mind at the last second and
save someone else's life cliche earlier
this machine could stop bullets in
midair and fire them back sure would be
handy if it did that now these MN you
guys can't hit moving targets worth a
crap as we've seen time and again but
the sure can hit Christopher Johnson's
shield a million times
there's Chris Johnson hesitating before
he hits the hole like he always does
kill you myself
then do it you had no problem trying to
kill him earlier now you want a
monologue
selfish hero sacrifices himself so the
oppressed dude can get away with his son
in Africa Blood Diamond much
illustrate the essential characteristics
of this brand-new predator class of
animals supervision great speed and
superior size